poussé beaucoup plus d'armes parce que
les immeubles maintenant se prendront
beaucoup trop peu années 60-70 les
villes s'étendent
elle accueille toujours plus d'habitants
au revoir les champs les forêts les
parcs et des immeubles sont érigés les
citadins et toute la ville verte devient
une ville grise
il ne reste plus qu'à fuir la ville fuir
peut-être pas mais reverdir c'est
aujourd'hui le tendance forte mais il y
est déjà eu des tentatives il ya une
quarantaine d'années
1973 les atouts du végétal en ville
était reconnu les jardins les
plantations d'arbres les bois à la
périphérie des villes ont un rôle
important
c'est un facteur notamment de lutte
contre la pollution atmosphérique est
également d' équilibre psychique du
citadin petit à petit des villes se sont
mises au vert les parcs sont plébiscités
tout comme les zones boisées
incontournable de l'aménagement de la
ville qui ont même gagné la conception
de bâtiments
l'exemple typique le projet de la cité
des choux à créteil à l'origine les
balcons de ces petits tours en forme
d'épi devait être végétalisé
ils ne l'ont finalement pas été au
milieu des années 2000 la france
commence à végétaliser des toits et des
murs bien après nos voisins européens
qui le font depuis les années 70
toujours est il que cette technique
permet des économies d'énergie
l'été il va nous protéger par son
feuillage et puis l'hiver au contraire
les feuilles vont disparaître et la
lumière et la chaleur de l'hiver va
rentrer beaucoup plus en profondeur à
l'intérieur du bâtiment du verre aussi
sur les toits en 2013 à paris le toit du
centre commercial de beaugrenelle a pris
des allures de champs en pleine ville
sept mille mètres carrés végétalisée est
un atout pour la biodiversité site
latine le fait d'installer des plantes
en fête diversifiée vous allez attirer
les insectes qui sont liées à ces
plantes qui vont les consommer ou qui
vont ils vont répondre et de là vous
allez attire les espèces d'oiseaux qui
vont les consommer des végétaux pour
recouvrir le béton la solution intéresse
de plus en plus de villes verdir les
façades replanter des arbres c'est
aujourd'hui envisagée comme arme anti
canicule contre la chaleur emmagasinée
par le béton et le goudron
[Musique]